foreign
so my life is reflected in my tattoos
and you're gonna have to trust me when I
say that I've got a lot of them
my body art tells a story now my HIV
tattoo is on one of my kneecaps which is
the joint that
through a career of playing professional
rugby was shot to Pieces but somehow
managed to get me through one of the
world's toughest Iron Man
and also more recently
a half marathon now I did these to show
what living with HIV is like now and
also to illustrate that HIV doesn't
restrict what I'm capable of doing
physically or mentally
the skull is
dark
ghoulish
threatening
it represents the imminent death that I
felt awaited me when I first had my
diagnosis the wings underneath the skull
are my tattoo signify the freedom I felt
when I finally found my voice it was
almost like the dead man coming back to
life the crown that adorns the skull's
head shows me as
someone willing to lead from the front
someone wanted to take the campaign
against discrimination and
misinformation forward
someone wanted to celebrate and
highlight people's truth never asking
people to do something I wouldn't now I
always I've always been like this
in 2019 I was blackmailed by somebody
who wanted money for their silence
also in that year a journalist went to
my parents house knocked on the door and
asked my parents to make comment on my
HIV status now at this point I hadn't
even told my parents myself
that forced me into telling the world
about my HIV diagnosis way before I was
ready I was still reeling from the
stigma of the diagnosis now stigma is
when people are seen in a negative way
due to a certain characteristic such as
race disability sexuality or health
challenges and it ends up with a making
a moral judgment about people and it
affects the way they treat them
now
I have spent my entire adult life in the
public eye
I'm an ex-professional Rugby Union
player I played a hundred times for my
country Wales and I captained the
British and Irish Lions it always felt
like I had the crowds cheering me from
the grandstands since then I've
presented and appeared on on many TV
shows
I've had an amazing life I felt loved by
those around me and by my country I was
I was this strong tough rugby player who
came from a simple working-class
background to be one of the very best at
their sport
I was married to a woman
but I was living a lie so in 2009 when I
became the first openly gay male
professional Rugby Union player it was a
defining moment for me
for sport
and for society
and even though it felt like a
breakthrough moment
sadly very few followed my path since
I am now living with HIV
it took me a long while to process it at
first right because I'd gone from a man
who had won every trophy that he had
ever dreamed of
to someone all of a sudden was living a
lie it was ashamed embarrassed isolated
afraid I was going to die afraid to tell
anyone afraid to tell my family afraid I
was going to lose everything and
everyone that I'd worked so hard for and
I loved so much I was afraid that from
now on I would be defined by a virus
I felt that devastating impact of stigma
and shame and that is why I am
determined to change the way people
perceive HIV and other stigmatized
conditions and here's why
the stigma and shame that I felt was
medically unfounded
science and medicine has come such a
long way in the last 20 years especially
around HIV that should be celebrated way
more than it is but people's attitudes
lag way behind
the fact is
I take one tablet a day
modern medicine prevents my HIV
progressing into AIDS
it suppresses the virus in my body which
means it becomes undetectable which
means I cannot transmit it to my husband
and I live a normal happy healthy life I
really do trust me I have never been
happier
foreign
HIV was positioned as a death sentence
it was reported as the gay plague
and those myths and misunderstandings
still exist today and levels of
awareness of what it is to live with HIV
remain way too low now I can tell you I
still experience stigma today
where there's people moving away from me
in a restaurant or people not wanting to
shake my hand
now people act like that are a sense of
fear out of a sense of wanting to keep
themselves safe but what it does it
creates a sense of Shame
and that shame means more people acquire
the virus and fewer people get early
treatment
because most people think that HIV
doesn't affect them
that it only affects gay and bisexual
men
when globally 54 of the people living
with HIV are female and in England in
2020 for the first time in a decade
there was more new cases of HIV among
heterosexual people than they were
amongst gay and bisexual men
the truth is anyone can gather about us
and the only way to know your status is
to get tested but stigma acts as a
barrier to testing so new cases continue
in the U.S 8 out of 10 new cases come
from people who are undiagnosed or who
are not on medication
now UNH has set a goal that by 2030 they
will end this epidemic but it's going to
be really hard to reach if stigma
continues to act as a barrier to test
and then seeking care
now
when I was pushed into a caller by the
blackmailer I'm by the media
I was going to come out if I did
I wanted to take control of my life I
wanted to know what it was like to feel
free I wanted to know and I had the
right to be able to live again
and I wanted anyone else who was in the
same position as me to have that right
as well
our tackling stigma is an ongoing
challenge it's going to take a
collective effort from policy makers
Healthcare officials advocacy
organizations
and more importantly all of us in the
General Public
education is key
the more people who know the facts the
more the truth spreads
even simple conversations between two
people can change Minds
and we need to normalize talking about
HOV and other stigmatized conditions and
I encourage you all to challenge any
stigma you encounter whether that be
mental health race disability sexuality
that we also need to address legal
inequality and discrimination now I feel
relatively lucky given the strides being
made in this regard living in the UK as
I am aware of people around the world
who are living with HIV that through
discrimination has limitations placed on
what they can and cannot do or even on
where they can and cannot live
now recently in the UK changes have
finally been made that means that people
living with HIV can join the armed
forces and be deployed or can train as
commercial airline pilots now these
changes have only happened thanks to the
determination and advocacy of those
involved people with a Target
determination to create safe stigma-free
environments
our stigma also exists in unexpected
places like within Healthcare you know
we'd all expect Healthcare professionals
to know the facts but this isn't always
the case especially outside of HIV
Specialists and this absolutely needs to
change as this can have a devastating
impact on people living with the virus
discouraging them from accessing care
now
I am very very very proud to lead the
tackle HIV campaign and we focus on that
first point education
and along with our charity Partners the
talents against trust and Vive
Healthcare which is an organization
fully focused on eradicating HIV and
AIDS
we are using the power of science
advocacy and Sport to change people's
attitudes
we draw on the ability of sport to
affect change right the love of
celebrity and the compelling stories of
those living with HIV can bring to
change people's behavior and
understanding
whether that be through media engagement
I podcast with others who've experienced
stigma or live on the ground initiatives
I am passionate passionate about
demonstrating that HIV is not a barrier
to anything whether that be through me
running an Iron Man Half Marathon or
just through my daily gym workouts
because when people can get beyond the
fact that HIV is no longer a death
sentence and they're on effective
medication it can become undetectable in
your body which means it's
untransmissible through sexual contact
then people living with HIV can live
without fear of rejection or alienation
and so the Fight Continues because in
some countries around the world
new cases of HIV arise in and in all of
these countries stigma continues to
exist but I guarantee you one day we'll
reach our goal
so when anyone encounters stigma
regardless of what the source of that
stigma is we can all play a part in
combating it we all have a part to play
when you see or hear any cases of
stigmatization find the strength to
challenge and correct it right whether
that be at home with your family out
with your friends or even in the wider
community
now the wings underneath my tattoo
give me the strength to move Beyond HIV
stigma and HIV shame and trust me all of
you please trust me if I can do it then
anyone can do it and then and only then
do we have a real chance of ending HIV
forever
so please
please help me because
together we can tackle stigma thank you
so much
[Applause]